on va l'aborder lenski qui s'est
affichée plutôt confiant devant ces
médias russes gauthier rybinski bonjour
on va décrypter ensemble c'est ses
propos et puis plus globalement l'état
d'avancée de ces négociations nous
présente cette semaine comme une semaine
importante dans la poursuite des des
négociations quand on l'entend volodymyr
ses colonies malaise qui s'est exprimé
ainsi on a le sentiment que finalement
ça peut se solder assez assez rapidement
c'est vrai cela
en tant que président de l'ukraine il
est forcément tenue vis-à-vis de sa
population d'essayer de lui donner un
minimum d'espoir notamment quand on voit
dans quel état se trouve la ville de
marioupol par exemple et de ceux qui
restent encore est évident que s'il ne
donne pas une lueur aux ukrainiens c'est
ça peut être un effondrement total donc
il ya d'abord ce premier ce premier but
le deuxièmement il apparaît toujours
depuis le début de ce2 ce conflit comme
étant celui qui essaye d'avancer comme
étant celui qui est une force de
proposition ou de réclamations de force
de réclamations aussi mais quelqu'un qui
essaye au fond d'eux d'apporter du
positif et qui est en contradiction
totale avec la position des russes qui
est restée crispée sur leurs objectifs
on voir peut-être tout à l'heure qu'ils
en ont bougé de 10 en ont changé mais en
même temps il ya ça alors sur la
question de la neutralité et
celle de la partition il faut bien voir
une chose c'est que la neutralité en
soit il ya les exemples only chiens et
suédois qui ne sont pas tout à fait la
même chose et qui garantirait à moscou
une forme de finalement de tampon
l'ukraine serait un tampon entre la
russie et l'occident et puis la
partition alors là on va peut-être le
voir sur eux sur la carte la partition
ça voudrait dire carrément vous voyez
ici donc les zones qui sont celles du
d'une basse au sens des républiques
autoproclamées et si on avance un peu
plus et qu on englobe attractif on
arrive à peu près à cette verticale à ça
c'est ce que pourraient être réclamés
revendiquer la russie évidemment de
l'autre côté souvenez vous les
occidentaux ont toujours dit qu'ils
défendre l intégrité territoriale de
l'ukraine et donc partant il y a une
chose très importante c'est que si il
fallait arriver à des négociations sur
ces deux sujets avec la russie l'ukraine
aurait besoin d'être en position de
force et c'est pour ça que ces derniers
jo zelensky a été très très plus que
violent lorsqu'il a dit aux occidentaux
au fond vous êtes des moves n'est pas de
courage et en parlant de marioupol dont
on parlait à l'instant cela dit si vous
aviez seulement vous à l'ouest 1% du
courage des habitants de marion
marioupol on serait déjà un peu mieux
dans l'oeuf un peu mieux loti donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya quelque chose de très
évidemment l'occident fait un peu
masochiste un effet comme si il aimait
bien se prendre des gifles mais la
revendication de zelensky elle est
simple si vous voulez la fin du conflit
il faut que nous les ukrainiens on
arrive en position de force et donc par
exemple grâce à la livraison d'appareils
mig qui sont adaptés aux compétences des
pilotes ukrainiens voila voila si vous
voulez le les deux les deux thèmes de
neutralité et de partitions qui sont
dans une éventuelle négociation mais pas
à n'importe quel prix c'est à dire pas
si les ukrainiens se retrouve
complètement tout seul alors parlons
justement de terrain il ya cette carte
derrière vous dont les lignes de front
finalement sont restés presque figé
pendant 2 bonjour on a longtemps dit
l'armée russe en difficulté qui c'est
une réalité se heurte à la résistance
des ukrainiens vient de revoir à
l'instance reportage de gwendoline de
bono les lignes restait figé pendant
plusieurs jours et les russes qui
affichent de nouveaux objectifs
finalement dans un premier temps elles
ont annoncé vouloir faire tomber le
gouvernement de volodine zelensky de
démilitariser aider nazifié
l'intégralité de l'ukraine et puis
aujourd'hui on annonce qu'on se
concentre essentiellement sur sur le
dombass un effet d'annoncé un coup de
bluff c'est quoi on est en train
d'essayer de sauver la face parce qu'on
est réellement en difficulté aussi
peut-être aujourd'hui c'est peut-être ça
un faute de grives on mange des merles
c'est à dire que quand on n'a pas réussi
à obtenir ce qu'on voulait eh bien il
faut faire semblant que tout cela on le
maîtrise et que c'était prévu vous le
savez l'état de l'armée russe s'est pas
qu'il est lamentable c'est simplement
qu'il pâtit d'un manque de préparation
de renseignement de renseignements sur
le terrain qui n'ont pas été
adaptés à la situation du fait aussi ça
c'est assez réjouissant c'est le fait
que une dictature au fond on travaille
toujours contre elle même ceux qui ont
eu les renseignements sur le terrain et
qui ont voulu les retransmettre aval il
admire poutine ont fini par avoir peur
de vladimir poutine qui avait une tout
autre idée sont dit on va les maquiller
ses enseignements dont vous voyez il ya
ce jeu là aussi mais finalement ce qui
pourrait se passer ça serait pour les
russes ça serait effectivement d'avoir
une dépolitisation de l'ukraine et de se
contenter de ce dôme basse mais avec une
idée très précise par exemple en cercle
et marioupol pour faire en sorte que les
forces ukrainienne soit séparé en deux
maintenant on peut pas exclure et j'en
terminerai là on peut pas exclure que ce
soit comme vous disiez une manoeuvre
parce que au fond quand on écoute
vladimir poutine quand on écoute ses
soutiens idéologique ces gens là vous
dise quoi vous dise l'ukraine n'existe
pas il faut l'annexé il faut la posséder
parce que l étain un poison on va dire
occidentale au sein de notre espace
vital parce que c'est presque ça et là
vous voyez qu'on s'a serait extrêmement
curieux que d'un jour à l'autre vladimir
poutine change son fusil d'épaulé
pardonner l'expression à moins que il
est compris que pour pérenniser son
régime et son maintien à la tête de la
russie il faut un petit peu reculé mais
dans ce cas-là ça voudrait dire quoi on
y revient pour me revenir après et puis
en profitant du fait que les occidentaux
sont très très soulagée de voir qu'à une
partition du mouvement que ça ne va pas
plus loin merci beaucoup gauthier pour
le